رانيا ليس مشجعا اعتياديا اسمه يزين قائمه
مشاهير كره القدم الايرانيه موسى سلامات
الحرب سلبته القدره على السمع والحركه في
طفولته لكن نعيشقه للساحره مستديره كان
اكبر من الحرب ومخلفاتها
يشهد على ان موسى رغم ظروفه القاسيه لم
يتغيب عن اي مباراه للفريق على مدار 24
[موسيقى]
الا تقل شهره عن الملاعب الدوليه في ايران
قمصان نوم كره القدم الايرانيه واخرى
لنجوم من دولي نزلوا ايران في مناسبات
الرياضيه كره لبطوله استضافتها ايران صور
تذكاريه صحف ميداليه واعلام وكل منها
تحديد جانبا من روايه عشق ابديه بين الرجل
وكره القدم
لا يمكن لهذا الرجل الذي اوشك على اكمال
رامز
في بطوله كاس العالم 2014
و2018 لا يتمكن هذه المره من مرافقه
المنتخب الايراني في مونديال قطر بسبب
تراجع سعر العمله الايرانيه ما ادى الى
ارتفاع تكاليف تذاكر الطيران والمباريات
لمبهذ بالنسبه الايرانيين
لكنه حيث توجد يحمس الايرانيين من خلال
نشاطه على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
ويمني نفسه بتالق منتخب بلاده في مونديال
قطر
[تصفيق]